c'était le 9 février 1957
robert et colette se disaient oui pour
le meilleur et pour le pire et ce samedi
11 février 2017
ils sont revenus en mairie pour célébrer
leurs 60 ans de mariage avec beaucoup
d'émotion chez ton mariage de mon frère
donc en 1954 et ensuite on s'est connus
on s'effraie compter et on s'est marié
en 57
je pense que chez moi vous connaissez
bien les femmes aussi
elles attendent le premier pas le maire
adjoint jean-marie bora a présidé cette
cérémonie une opportunité et un moment
exceptionnel que ce soit les noces d'or
ou les noces de diamant ce qui est
encore plus rare c'est toujours le maire
qu'il le fait est là
le maire est en vacances on est en
pleines vacances scolaires
et c'est pour ça que étant l'élu
d'astreinte
j'ai eu l'honneur et le plaisir de
présider cette cérémonie des voisins des
proches et la famille étaient présents
et parmi eux la fille et la petite fille
de robert et colette
moi j'ai divorcé va très très tôt pour
diverses raisons voilà aussi j'aurais
bien aimé un jour fêter mes soixante ans
de mariage je ne fêterai jamais quoi que
ce soit mais voilà ça m'inspire que on
sait mais je pense différemment il ya
celle de cela 50 60 ans qu'aujourd'hui
j'espère que si un jour je me marie je
ne pense pas je pourrais les faits été
moi même puisque en moyenne ans mike
vernon 30 ans 35 ans donc voilà je suis
plus à mes études en ce moment c'est mon
métier et où est ma passion qui va
passer quand même avant
avant ma future vie de famille et pour
la saint valentin le couple
soixantenaire a aussi un message pour
les plus jeunes la quiche aime autant
que nous c'est le seul message qu'on
peut passer pour eux le rendez vous est
pris le 9 février 2000 27 pour leurs 70
ans de mariage